are you the type that feels the need to
travel through the office on wheels
get off that razor scooter and really
impress your colleagues with the
solowheel it's the most dangerous object
in the office this month here are some
guidelines to get you started your lower
legs should rest comfortably yet firmly
against the leg pads keep your posture
upright but relaxed while resting your
arms comfortably at your sides
the gyro sensors prevent the machine
from tumbling forwards or backwards but
side to side stability is up to you
shift your body weight forward to pick
up speed twist your feet left and right
for balance and steering lastly it's
recommended that you wear a safety
helmet or other protective gear or not